the power of protein today and here to
show us how you can get more approaching
into your day while saving calories
that's the key dietitian Abby sharp how
can you increase your protein well I
mean if we're gonna increase the protein
or cut down on calories yeah we've got
two other macro nutrients to play with
we've got the fat and the carbs right
so if protein is going up we know the
cards and the fat have to go down a
little bit right but the good news is
protein is so inherently safe cheating
you can actually eat fewer calories and
still feel really sad yeah because you
that's the thing and happen you have to
feel satisfied yeah so let's talk about
hello pancake hello pan yeah all right
so that's a bit there's a couple
pancakes there people Tara so breakfast
I find is the hardest meal for people to
get that protein and they like their
carbs in the morning so with we've got
three pancakes they're about 1/4 cup
size each yeah with 2 tablespoons of
maple syrup
lots of sugar lots of cars lots of fat
going on happiness happy yeah sundaes
special yeah right we can still have
pancakes so I made these pancakes with
cottage cheese oatmeal and egg whites
why through a few blueberries in there
you get a bigger portion how many do you
like pancakes
okay and look at the comparison here we
can cut about a hundred calories right
there and a bigger portion right also I
want to mention I didn't use maple syrup
I took raspberries boiled them down to
make a nice little syrup high in fiber
so when you compare the stats we've got
one gram of fiber here 6.25 that's about
a quarter your fiber needs
mm-hmm and then we go from 7 grams of
protein to 27 grams at breakfast that's
pretty big okay no being a true Canadian
as we all are we do love our maple syrup
it's okay in moderation of clearance
right but like I said if we're trying to
cut those that's right cut those carbs
cut those calories you just boil a
Centauri sauce that's for you I like
that I love sandwiches I really do but I
worry about the bread and let's talk
about how good this one log totally
simple tuna salad sandwich right two
slices of white bread two ounces of oil
packed tuna in a tablespoon of mayo
so the
I'll pack tuna we know a little higher
in fat mayo I don't need to tell you is
hired you know high in calories high in
for that time we can do better than that
right so I'm using Ezekiel bread with
black so you love that wine I know I
love this event it's delicious but it's
higher in fiber and protein really Hardy
so you really only need one slice so we
can go open-faced with this Sam way I've
used the water packed tuna instead of
the oil pack tuna so I hit up the
portion sides we've got three ounces of
tuna here instead of the two but now
we've got a little bit more protein yeah
and instead of mayo fat-free plain Greek
yogurt
that's what's gonna ask you how did you
find the answer yeah absolutely
it's my favorite substitute for any Mayo
or sour cream it's high in fiber low in
fat low in carbs really low in calories
the best and that looks delicious
so if we compare these believe it or not
I've almost cut the calories in half
with Wow
we've also annihilated the fat here from
sixteen point six grams to one point
seven which is crazy boosted up the
fiber and we went from under 20 grams to
28 grams right here that's amazing
absolutely pump up the protein I like
that team it it looks delicious
mm-hmm okay now dinner what's for dinner
yeah so we all love a little bit of
Chinese take it every once in a while so
Chinese chicken fried rice this starts
with 3/4 of a cup of white rice I call
it filler rice you know there's not a
whole lot of nutrition going on there
not a lot of fiber there not a lot of
protein two ounces of thigh chicken meat
so little higher in calories and fat
than your breasts and we've got some
eggs sauteed in there with some sesame
oil so it's a little high in fat there
so there's some protein in it so we've
got some egg in there but it's a whole
egg so we've got some room to play with
some wiggle room I've used quinoa
instead of the white rice quinoa is a
great source of protein of fiber and
I've shrunk the portion little to a half
a cup okay how the cups have much more
reasonable portion it's it's still it
still fills everything out nicely so we
have chicken breasts instead of the
thigh meat and I've used the egg white
instead of the whole egg to saute it up
there and I've really cut down on the
amount of the
amount of fat I've used in the recipe
because if you're using a nonstick
skillet you don't actually need to use
tons and tons of oil when you saute or
an earth stir-fry and I've added some
edamame love edamame do you not love it
I love that I just I just never think to
put it I want to go out I get it but
again it's frozen you throw it into your
stir-fry adds that protein so delish and
fiber and I've also boosted up the
portion and the fiber with some broccoli
some bell peppers lots of veggies look
how beautiful it looks now let's see the
numbers now we're totally with you two
here yeah we've cut 100 calories good
we've cut the fat in half we've boosted
up that fiber and we went from about 20
grams under 20 grams to 30 grams of
protein right there that's amazing so
we've really hit the mark and you know
in all these cases too it will fill you
a hundred percent yeah even though you
are eating fewer calories throughout the
day you do feel so much more satisfied
because that protein is so much more
inherently satiating thank you Abbi okay
so all of your low calorie protein rich
recipes on Maryland dogs today thank you
so much now we don't forget for lunch
today
we don't take a break we'll be right
back
coming up